Hey guys, it's me, Marina Joyce--
No.
But welcome to the end of another year here on YouTube,
here on CZsWorld,
and what a year it was.
Best year that I can remember.
We had this happen.
And then this happened.
And don't forget that this happened,
and then this happened, which was pretty much the highlight of my life.
And despite YouTube being broken for the last two months,
this was still the biggest year we had for subscriber growth here on CZsWorld.
So you may have heard that YouTube is broken.
Now what does that mean?
So basically YouTube is unsubscribing people from accounts that they're subscribed to
and failing to deliver you the videos from the channels that you are subscribed to.
So what can you do to make sure that you don't miss my videos in 2017?
Well, a couple things.
First, make sure you're subscribed.
Second, hit that bell button next to the subscribe button
and make sure you turn on notifications.
And the third thing you can do is leave, on every video,
like 50 comments and 20 likes.
Well, you can only leave 1 like per video, but
the thing is, I guess engagement is now going to be really important on YouTube,
so liking and leaving a comment is going to be more important than ever.
I wouldn't want you to miss any of the videos in 2017 because there is a lot of great stuff planned for next year.
I'm going to be working with a couple of new collaborators
who you'll meet here in the coming months.
Actually, this is one of them.
But you'll get to meet both of them formally in a short period of time.
So with that being said I'll take you out one last time here in 2016.
Subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every other week,
and I'll see you next year.
Assuming..
the obvious.